[Music]
all right well here's somebody whose
wardrobe may rival theirs Madonna she
turns 60 today can you believe it that's
amazing and a mark the occasion well she
posted her performance up like a prayer
from the Met Gala and clearly imagine
isn't shying away from celebrating this
birthday milestone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's time to celebrate because after all
McDonough has never shied away from her
milestones I mean I know when I was
younger the idea of being 40 seemed like
such a long ways away it is about being
hungry and you know it is about your
state of mind
EG first met the ambitious 25 year old
in 1984 dressed in full 80s fashion on
the set of her now iconic music video
I'm at the beginning of a very fruitful
career and I know it's just a matter of
time I'm saying what I feel I mean
they're my words and my thoughts and
that makes me more in control of the
situation that makes me rare for a
female singer in the music industry
people listen I guess that means you got
something to say right the birthday girl
has always gotten people's attention and
she definitely got ours in 2004 where we
took her on a London pub crawl
stick around baby I'm going to show you
[Music]
and boy did she I'm from that's why I
like drink beer she even questioned one
of her long-standing nicknames
what does everybody call me that what
you likely call them Her Royal Highness
that's who I am
I knew she didn't like mad Majesty but
okay well that's it she probably does
like sweet right that's true likes my
Donna
[Music]